so as the field of 2024 Republican
candidates grows well South Carolina
Senator Tim Scott he was back in Iowa
today fueling more speculation about a
possible White House bid let's take a
look
Senator Scott if you are potentially
considering a 2024 run what are your
thoughts on the RNC potentially
requiring a loyalty pledge well the most
important thing I can do is focus on the
faith in America Tour because bottom
line is as I hear more from the
constituents here in Iowa and around the
country it will give me more information
on what to do next all right joining us
now Senator Tim Scott he is in the great
state of Iowa Senator good to see you
appreciate you being here
if you go to Iowa and then you go to
your home state of South Carolina and
you end up in New Hampshire I think the
odds are pretty high that you're
thinking about a run for the presidency
are you
well today I thought about why I love
this country so much I had a chance this
morning Sean to visit Saint Anthony's
Catholic school with Governor Reynolds
she just passed Monumental school choice
one of my most important issues I've
been fighting on we had a chance to meet
with faith leaders speak at Drake
University do a radio show and I just
finished with the Polk County GOP it has
been a good day I'm learning a lot and
as you know Sean the most important
thing we can do is listen to our bosses
the constituents at home and across the
country
all right so the names that we hear we
know Nikki Haley is uh throwing her hat
in the ring we know uh president Trump
was the first to announce that he will
run again in 2024 but then you hear
names like uh governor sununu in New
Hampshire Larry Hogan in Maryland uh you
hear names like Ron DeSantis in in
Florida uh Glenn Younkin in in Virginia
um and others
uh what are the differences in terms of
policy positions that's for example you
may have with President Trump
probably not very many at all I am so
thankful that we have President Trump in
office frankly the policies that we were
able to pass from 2017 to 2020 were a
Monumental and thank God we went into
covid with a strong economy we brought
the unemployment rates for
African-American Hispanics for women
Asians all to all-time lows or the
lowest since World War II we passed
opportunity zones so my signature
legislation that brought more than 29
billion dollars back to the poorest
communities just in 2019 leading to the
lowest level of poverty ever recorded as
a country I think the policies that we
fight for as conservatives are the
policies necessary to stop the Democrats
from ruining America so might might we
then find ourselves in a position where
you know maybe we'll have six seven
eight maybe ten maybe 20 Republican
candidates dates on a stage that mostly
agree on what the governing philosophy
and ideology should be for the country
what works for the country uh then where
are the differences what would the
differences be do you think
that's a great question John I would
simply say this what I'm learning on my
faith in America Tour is as I tell my
story as an African-American who's born
into poverty and then a single parent
household the strength of my community
my Chick-fil-A Mentor who happened to be
a white guy a citadel graduate from in
South Carolina he taught me that you no
matter where you're born you can rise
beyond your circumstances if you're
willing to perspire because you're
inspired by the American story leaning
into that helped change my life bringing
people together black folks and white
folks not because of the color of our
skin but because we have one single
Focus we believe in the goodness of
America I want to share with people why
we should be proud of who we are and at
the same time debunk the lies of the
Progressive Party that's Now using race
as a weapon in our country in a way that
we haven't seen in three or four decades
it is just pitiful
I would give you medical advice but I
made a made a pledge to myself during
covet I wouldn't however you might want
to ask your doctor about Prednisone when
I would be on the road a lot that would
be the one thing that would lower the
inflammation of my vocal cords but you
still sound great ah thank you but I'm
not giving that recommendation anyway
Senator great to have you we appreciate
you always being on the program thank
you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else